all things knowing. This is a
reference and a description of
one of the miracles of Suleiman
Alaihi Salam. that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala subjected
the wind to his command. and
that is that travel for
Suleiman, for his army,
was often by way of of of
traversing the wind. Air
travel.
we have elements of that in our
time. It's Suleiman Alaihi
Salam, the wind would blow. And
the wind would carry him. as he
chose at the speed he chose, at
the direction he chose, chose,
and and eventually, he would
return to the land which Allah
had blessed. Meaning, the land
that he resided in, the land of
Hashem, the land of Palestine.
Allah then says that which
translates to and of the devils
were those who dived for him
and did work other than that.
Allah gave Suleiman the ability
and command over
the devils from amongst the gin
kind. that Suleiman Alaihi
Salam would command them with
something and they would have
to and they would have to
fulfill it. They would have to
do what he commanded. And if
they were insubordinate,
Suleiman Alaihi Salam was given
the ability to punish the Jin.
And
Punish them with imprisonment
and so forth. It's mentioned by
some of the scholars that
Suleiman Alaihi Salam had the
ability to confine
that were insubordinate. Those
who refused his command. He was
able to confine them in a way
that noone else was able to do.
This is something which is
specific to Suleiman Alaihi
Salam.
a sense that he, the devils,
being at his beckoned call, No
one has been able to do this
from amongst the prophets after
him. Not to the extent that
Suleiman Alaihi Salam was able.
They would also do other things
they would dive for him.
Diving diving in the water. Of
course, the the they are made
of elements of fire. This
doesn't mean that they still
are fire. They have obviously
metamorphosized in their
creation. Though their origins
are similar to the origins or
elements found in fire, it
doesn't mean that they are
fire. So, there's no there's no
issue here with the diving in
water or being punished in the
hellfire or being being you
know enjoying
paradise and so forth.
They would die for him
extracting some of the deep sea
treasures, that were found
therein.
Earls and Oral and Go forth
Likewise Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentioned that. These
devils, the would also design
statues for him and bring him
things and the stories of these
feats are all through the
Quran. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala he mentions and we were
of them a guardian.
Meaning that Suleiman Alaihi
Salam would command something
and Allah had made it that they
would obey his command. Not
only that but he would protect
Suleiman, Alaihi Salam, that
they would, that they would
harm Suleiman.
obeying the command of
Suleiman. They didn't want to.
They had to. They were forced
to. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
then goes on to mention the
story very briefly the story of
Ayub Alaihi Salam. Job. Allah
says and mention Job. When he
called to his Lord indeed
adversity has touched me, has
afflicted me, and you are the
most merciful of those who show
mercy.
That is that
was
afflicted with extreme
hardship, both financial
hardship, as well as
health wise and the length of
time that he was ill for, the
length of time that he was
afflicted with this hardship is
not exactly known. Different
times have been mentioned, Some
mentioned eight years, some
mention 10 years, others
mention 18 years. This is a
very popular opinion amongst
the scholars. However, it's not
specified to us in the Quran or
in the authentic narrations of
the prophet the of time that
Ayub Alaihi Salam was faced
with this adversity. What we do
know that he was faced with
adversity. He was faced with
adversity health wise. He was
faced with adversity
financially and socially.
Meaning that because of his
illness, people were very
reluctant to come near him. And
this was a test from Allah
Subhana which we will mention
in greater detail tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]